One quick note.
If, instead of doing this in black and
white, you were actually doing this in
red, green, blue, in a colored version,
right, you would now have, instead of
25 equations, you'd have how many?
You'd have 75 equations,
five times five times three.
Now, if you're really shrewd,
you might say wait a minute, wait,
wait, suppose my window
was only a single pixel.
You told me professor Bobbitt
that we had this problem, okay?
That we had one equation and
two unknowns.
But with R, G and B I now have
three equations, and two unknowns.
Can't I solve it?
>> Well, no Frodo,
you can not, all right?
The problem is is that the R,
G and B images,
you can just think of the image planes,
are quite correlated, okay?
So, you know,
you have a change of intensity but
you had the same changes of intensity
because of the edge of my shirt,
both in the green and in,
and in the blue channels.
Now one might get brighter and
one might get darker but the gradients
will be in the same direction.
So the gradients are very correlated, so
you can't just use the different
color planes in order to solve it.
Good try though, sort of.